this video refers to the original dune
saga only though thinking machines were
banned during the butler in jihad 10,000
years before the start of the first dune
novel other forms of technology are
still prominent and necessary though
they are not focused on like in many
other science fiction series
ornithopters were the most common small
transport vessels used in the Imperium
ornithopters are capable of carrying
nine passengers maximum but they were
very versatile though they are capable
of short distance space travel they were
mainly used on planet since ornithopters
were likely to be used in military
operations they were generally equipped
with weaponry such as lace guns and mala
pistols which were usually handheld and
used to fire poison darts groundcars
were more traditional vehicle they
combined wheels and either anti-gravity
floater bulbs or suspenders on Arrakis
ground cars were mostly without
anti-gravity systems due to the fact
that the Holtzman effect maddened the
great worms into violent rage still
suits recycled the body's water and
regulated the temperature of someone in
the deep desert they consisted of
multiple layers that absorb the moisture
through sweating and urination a filter
would then purify the moisture into
drinkable water still tents were also
used on Arrakis these tints were
airtight and made it so that the
humidity inside could be kept poisoned
snoopers were common in noble houses
they were mechanical devices that could
detect traces of poison and food
poisoned snoopers were commonly of
exceed manufacture biological technology
is also found in tune the Tleilaxu have
the ability to produce golus humans
replicated from the cells of dead
individuals and grown inside of living
organisms called axolotl tanks dis trans
is another technology used by the
Tleilaxu and which information can be
implanted into a person's mind or inside
of an animal for storage and later
retrieval this information was stored
subliminally through a form of voice and
could be retrieved by a code word the
Holtzman effect is a scientific theory
in the Dune universe the theory concerns
the repellent force of quantum particles
this effect allows for important pieces
of technology to exist the most
important of these technologies is space
travel the Holtzman effect has the
ability to fold space allowing for
faster than light travel from one place
in the universe to the next the spacing
guild maintained a monopoly on faster
than light travel until the exits broke
it with the creation of their own
navigation machine which did not require
spice the exact nature of these Ixia no
ships is not explored in depth but it is
mentioned that they utilized advanced
calculation systems that did not require
the prescient powers of a guild
navigator to traverse safely through the
universe anything inside of a no ship
was hidden from prescient sight or any
other method of detection no ships are
an example of technology that pushes the
boundaries of the but Larian Jihad their
existence was representative of the
fading restrictions on Thinking Machines
after the death of later the second the
Holtzman effect is also responsible for
the existence of shields in the dune
universe shields repelled most fast
moving projectiles but slower moving
objects like knives could easily pass
through a shield the creation of shields
greatly affected human warfare since
shields reacted violently when coming
into contact with lasers weapons like
lays on speak a min credibly danger
forcing mankind to revert to the use of
handheld weapons like swords glow globes
and suspense errs are other practical
uses of the Holtzman effect suspense
errs like the ones utilized by the Baron
Harkonnen and dune nullify gravity and
glow globes produced self-powered light
suspended by the effect dune is a
humanist series the technology is simply
part of the setting the philosophies of
dune takes centre focus while the tech
remains in the background and has given
very little focus or detail by Frank
Herbert
[Music]